one of the chaotic effects that Donald
Trump is having on the Republican Party
is forcing Republican insiders to
prepare for a contested convention known
to some as a brokered convention and
what this means is basically you get to
the convention which happens to be in
July of 2016 in Cleveland Ohio for the
2016 Republican convention you get to
the convention with no single candidate
having a majority of the delegates
before the convention starts so you
might have I don't know Donald Trump
with thirty percent of the delegates to
date and ben Carson with twenty percent
whatever right but nobody has a majority
so when this happens you have to start a
sort of brokering process where you
start negotiating for different
delegates maybe Ted Cruz can get Marco
Rubio's delegates to come over to him
and ben Carson is able to get Donald
Trump's delegates to come to him with
the promise that Trump would be his
running mate or who knows what and
according to a number of people very
familiar with Republican insiders 20
Republican officials and insiders met
for dinner last week in Washington DC
along with the RNC Chairman Reince
Priebus to discuss how are we going to
get Donald Trump out of here if we get
to the convention with no majority so
what would the reaction be what would
they do a few options were discussed
first possibility number one is they
could get a bunch of the Republican
delegates to unite around not Trump so
you get to the convention let's say
Trump has thirty percent of the
delegates to date that means he doesn't
have seventy percent of the delegates to
date so if you can get Republican
insiders Mitch McConnell is being
discussed in a number of others to go
around and say listen the Carson
supporters and the Rubio supporters and
the Jeb supporters and everybody else we
don't want Donald Trump to be the
nominee let's unite and coalesce our
delegates to prevent Trump from being
the nominee this is sort of the idea
that is being discussed there are more
aggressive ideas right going to the
state level and trying to actually ask
Trump from some of the primaries more
complex politically certainly more
dangerous the fact that there is even
a meeting taking place the fact that 20
Republican insiders have coordinated
their schedules to meet for dinner on a
weekday with the RNC Chairman to talk
about what will we do if Trump stays in
the lead that is already hugely damaging
to the republican party because they
can't spend time talking about how to go
after Hillary or Bernie yeah and i am of
the mindset that we shouldn't have
delegates in the first place uh but
anyway we do uh delegates are people I
mean they're kind of like voters yeah
and we know how the Republican Party
overall feels about Donald Trump so uh
yeah I mean I think everyone is
conspiring here and somehow Donald Trump
is still you know in full entertainer
mode maintaining his lead and I think
there's gonna be a lot of drama here
it's been funny to see the Republican
side more and more on Trump start to
sort of adjust their their barometer
first it was lesson Trump's not going to
run then it was well he's not going to
get any traction whatsoever and then
it's all well he's gonna be out soon
even though he's starting to pull well
and then it's well he's polling well now
and he's gonna stay in for a while but
he's eventually going to fade away
without winning any states and now it's
well he might win some states but we're
gonna figure out how to get him out of
the convention I don't know how far he
will go my position from the get-go has
been Donald Trump will not be the
eventual Republican nominee and I stand
by that what happens between now and the
announcement of the eventual nominee I
don't know but I maintain Trump will not
be the Republican nominee I hope for the
benefit of Bernie Sanders or Hillary
Clinton that struck Trump stays in this
as long as possible yeah that's it's
good for all involved good certainly
good for the media and anyone reporting
on what's happening in politics it's uh
yeah I'd I hate to say it but Donald
Trump is really just great business for
everybody